[Music]
and now from
arizona's largest and most respected
broadcast news team
this is cool news 10 with bill close
mary jo west joe doherty and
anthony martinez
[Music]
now the only thing that convinced me is
when i see myself
who wanted to get his message across he
wanted the world to know what god had
told him
he also made it clear with a gun to
production assistant louis via's head
and his arm around via's neck that he
was willing to kill to get his story
before the public
shortly after seven after talks with
anchorman bill close who was on the
phone with law enforcement officials
joe agreed to release two of his
hostages floor director jack webb
and cameraman bob cimino two and a half
hours into the ordeal
with cool employees anxiously watching
on closed circuit monitors
joe made his first verbal death threat
he wanted his message
to be televised
us to relay to you mr gwyn is it all
right for our
guests to leave the studio now or you
may leave now
this is the script that mr guinn gave me
and i'm going to read it verbatim
and uh anytime you wish to interrupt me
all right and mr gwyn writes
you're getting the feedback you're
getting the feedback
you're on uh my name is joe gwynne
i am a watchman read the 33rd chapter of
ezekiel
this is about the story of the ten
prophets the ten prophets are johnny
cash
ronnie milsap eddie rabbit larry gatman
hank williams jr rex allen jr willie
nelson
conway twitty loretta lynn lacey j
dalton tanya tucker barbara mondrell
joe gwynne detroiter
i saw a movie islam is using something
called sociology on children
in schools across america today islam
is using this sociology on children they
used it on my generation
to start the hippie movement and drugs
and on today's generation to turn them
into punks
and punk rockers by hypnotism in the
next two years there will be five new
cities started in the united states
mr glenn before i read these cities or
anything you want to say at this moment
oh yeah all right thank you the bible
says that there would be an alliance
between the two northern powers
that border at the polar circle russia
is one and canada
is and the other unless about 70 million
people migrate to canada
and make it a power this is in the bible
the angel showed me but i didn't write
it down
like all my dreams and visions now with
my first prediction
i have something to say yes okay
i'm going to move this microphone over
so that you can
okay why don't you just hold it okay
president reagan
islam is using sociology on your son
ricky ricky tell your father
what they're doing they're using
sociology
and that they use it to turn you into a
punk
this is our last chance we can only do
this when your father is in office
let's stop these people this is our only
chance to stop them
from using sociology on anybody again
okay you want me to continue reading
this now he's probably going to
hook up the microphone again
after the british military base on
ascension islands are destroyed
london will be destroyed by an atomic
bomb let me interrupt here
mr guin do you want to turn up the
volume to make sure that
this is going on the air just
you hear it now let me get let me get
over here so that you can
i'll get over here now you you get close
and listen can you hear me on that set
now
wherever the speaker can you hear me now
yeah see we are on the air
britain won't even fight back they won't
even resist this will be the fall of
britain
johnny cash you will have 72 hours to
tell the queen to evacuate london
72 hours after the destruction of
ascension island
the philosopher's stardate 12153
oklahoma city oklahoma just after
midnight
and that's the end of what you wrote for
me to read mr glenn
do you have anything that you'd like to
say no no more
is that it can we now can i say
something like we now return to our
regular programming
uh this has been a special broadcast
that mr gwen insisted that we make we
hope that you understand will bear with
us we think that his message is a very
important one to him
we appreciate your attention and now we
return to our
regular programming
i got a sweaty palm i want to shake
hands you really do
you bet i told you i was playing this
fair
did you think i you didn't trust me all
this time
oh hell it's all right leave him alone
it's okay put down the guns i have the
gun
back off with the guns
[Music]
good evening well after five hours it is
over what you saw
on your air during the last hour were
final moments of a terrifying hostage
drama
well it was acted out in our cool
television studios and it was all too
real the situation quite simply is this
a gunman who entered the cool tv studio
minutes before our 5 pm news is now in
police custody
four hostages including veteran cool
anchorman bill close
have been freed all are safe as part of
the gunman's demands regular programming
here on cool tv was interrupted at about
9
30 tonight now what you've seen and are
seeing again
a tape replay of those moments the
gunman identified as 29 year old joe
gwynne
said he had a message to deliver a
message from god about the impending
violence gwen said he foresees
upon the earth as close read gwen's
message and a list of demands
there was a gun remember this a gun
pointed at his stomach
following the broadcast gwen surrendered
without resistance
there's a gentleman that's behind me
right now who
well we're all very proud of bill close
and bill
just would like to get some of your
thoughts tonight what went through your
mind
during those hours
i guess the important thing to my mind
is when do we get this mess over with
i was very concerned for louis via
safety
because every once in a while uh
joe gwynne would get a little excited he
would tense up
and uh he
would pull back the hammer on that gun
and as you know all you have to do is
release the hammer and it goes off you
don't pull the trigger
i was afraid for louis i did not want
to let myself be afraid
because i felt that i had to
well this may sound cocky i felt i had
to be in control of what was going on
and i
and i was afraid that he might
if his demands were not exceeded to use
the gun on louis and i was prepared to
to go for him were you you bet
what would you have done grab the gun no
i wouldn't have grabbed the gun out i
hit him where
a woman is supposed to hit a man when uh
the man has dishonorable intentions you
would have done it you darn right
uh he's a heck of a guy
we're glad you're okay hey so am i you
have a terrific vacation
i'm going to have a terrific vacation i
think i might go home and uh
kiss my wife you bet well shall we close
the newscast the way we usually do it
all right okay and that brings us right
up to date on the news
so for the cool news team have a good
evening good night
[Applause]
this has been cool news 10. arizona's